the most amazing tarte tatin they are
pink peppercorns and I really good they
don't taste anything my black
peppercorns my sweet darling
they're really sweet very fruity the
pink peppercorns give it the sweetness
the black peppercorns give the heat now
what is that baby vanilla this is one of
the easiest desserts in the world to
make but one of the most delicious this
is sort of take on the classic apple or
pear to tan but when you caramelize
those bananas with a peppercorns and the
vanilla tastes amazing oh my goodness
incredible
okay can I made the camera start off
with a cold pan first you just press
that budget in there how comes you do it
let it just melt naturally because I
want the butter to stay cold because I'm
gonna stick the bananas in there okay
and then we'll make the caramel and
caramelize the bananas at the same time
so in goes those vanilla C's pods in
there as well okay peppercorns done yeah
good girl sprinkle them over that butter
just naturally naturally ice and then
not just very carefully sprinkle sugar
over that roughly the same size wedge it
into the butter won't you know what want
the bananas really caramelized
you just stuck them between if you'd
crammed them in like this okay it'll
stop them moving around nothing's moving
nothing is okay so all wedged in there
remove the peppercorns on top of the
bananas so for that flavor in the camel
and on the top and the bottom right puff
pastry puff pastry is difficult and
time-consuming to make so I always buy
ready-made when I'm at home
to get the best flavor and texture go
for the all butter type and keep your
pastry cold before using it this is
where it gets really exciting you get
your fingers you just pinch the end so
we've thin the end if you do that for me
very carefully have to be quick because
the heat your fingers can melt the
pastry how comes you do it because we
get it nice and thin so we can clip it
underneath
now take a spoon what we do is lift up
that banana and tuck it underneath like
a possum and see the thin bits of pastry
how easy it is to get it underneath yeah
and that's why you thin them out you do
it so quickly well because I have to be
quick otherwise the paste will melt
notice how we're not using anything
sharp so we're not would that cut the
pastry that's right so you have lockdown
that is mm-hmm guess on
we'll start caramelizing there those
three little holes are so important if
we didn't put a hole in the patient it
will cause the last theme to the pastry
never cooks it just goes really soggy oh
yes so really important the cameras live
now we're working the camel give a
little shake
how can you see the caramel through the
pastry look what happens when it tilts
see all comes running down
see ya a nice tea now that pastry okay
is like clinging on to the bananas and
said when we turn upside down
well there's love full of these
canonized bananas look at that it looks
loke look a lucky lucky ah like a like a
[Music]
nice birthday soon 15 I just worked it
out I'm like 50th you're 18
back there we should do a joint party
yeah love it too for the old ones 12
lunchtime time to fall for the old once
they can go to sleep
mega later
is where I get excited now look at the
color of that caramel so tilt the pan
again see how dark it is now 20 minutes
in the oven 190 to 200 degrees for our
banana tart attack so see now where that
pastry is caramelized so dark and just a
little tip gas back on that will release
it because if you tip it and it's still
sticking hmm then some of you bananas
will stick
yeah so now see what it starts spinning
around like that it's moving around and
here we are the moment of truth when you
know your daddy is the best chef in the
world ready yep
[Music]
the vanilla how delicious
my version of a classic at Loras
lavender creme caramel for dessert
[Music]
the first job is the lavender sugar you
can buy this ready-made or simply add
dried edible sprigs of lavender to
castor sugar and store you can also try
this trick with vanilla pods and
cinnamon to bring new subtle flavors to
sweets and bacon
[Music]
for the creme caramel milk plain castor
sugar until it turns dark golden pour
into ramekins sprinkled with lavender
flowers and cool now to make a simple
custard gently heat whole milk in a pan
until steaming meanwhile whisk together
egg vanilla seeds and lavender sugar
until golden and fluffy and gradually
pour the hot milk into the mix whisking
continuously until the custard is smooth
and creamy to set cook in a water bath
or bommali a good tip is to line a
roasting tin with a cloth to stop the
ramekins jiggling around pour your
custard then boiling water around the
ramekins until halfway of the sides then
cook in a preheated oven for around 30
minutes until set cool in the fridge
then when you're ready to serve dip the
ramekins in hot water to loosen the
creme caramel
[Music]
they've wanna lavender cling caramel
[Music]
so if you're on wrapper chocolate start
breaking up in little bits we're gonna
make the most amazing white chocolate
mousse our first job is to bring half of
our cream up to the boil so what kind of
cream is that in there dad
that is double cream okay so that's
gonna make a really nice rich chocolate
mousse what's your favorite sort of
chocolate is it white milk dark and I
love white milk
what's yours I absolutely love milk
chocolate is it really here we go
cream in so that goes in there now you
can see what's happening straight away
can you
nothing really quickly so okay oh excuse
me
Alicia would jump is white so you
weren't spotted yeah nice little snack
in another bowl add lime zest a cold
cream and whisk until it forms soft
peaks the lime cuts the sort of richness
of the cream and that starts to make
chocolate mousse tastes a little bit
lighter it smells really good the man
gives it a really nice
zing zing us you have see what next add
to the melted chocolate mixture because
I'm whisking is just getting lighter and
lighter and lighter how it'll taste mmm
nice yeah tell me I need the rest of the
mousse my dummy no come on chocolate
mousse into the fridge
[Music]
and next job is to separate out three
egg whites this is where I need you at
your absolute best okay because to whip
those whites is gonna be really tough
so we'll take you in turns 30 seconds
each okay
you go first ten seconds gone twenty
fifteen seconds gone 20 seconds gone
come on you can do it ten seconds to go
five four three two one and change
Thanks hold the bowl right
[Music]
Mathilda that's the best way of whippin
of egg whites
very happy in there so I contentious
whipped egg whites will make our mousse
light and airy and when they've reached
soft peaks we can gently mix in our
cooled white chocolate and cream mixture
once the egg whites hit the cream yeah
the chocolate sets egg whites keep the
cream nice and fluffy and you get this
nice light mousse in the bowl now I need
you to crush some raspberries please
with some fresh mint
now take your mousse
Wow that looks really cool
now look at that down the bottom there
now I'll spray delicious now they'll set
that in the fridge it's gonna be secured
open the door please our yummy white
chocolate mousse will take at least two
hours to set Holly darling help Danny
with the dessert yes please and the lamb
cutlets now we all know that you love
desserts yeah we do a little yogurt
parfait with some macerated fruits so
the first thing I'd like you to do is I
take a tablespoon of icy sugar dust that
over the fruits good now that's perfect
Donny thank you zest the orange over the
fruits what's gonna happen now it's
gonna start to sort of marinate and
there was some buzz in there that'll
make it really flavor some fresh puzzle
in and then to give that little mix up
I'm gonna squeeze some fresh orange
juice in there nice and gently
okay how gorgeous are those berries look
now okay we just leave them just
marinate okay and that's what we call
macerated berries now for the mango
Sunday my magazine please I love nice
now they're naturally sweet
now how fresh does that smell
now you'd love art right yeah so you're
gonna put these together so nice little
dollop of mango at the bottom nice and
slowly once each class has a layer of
mango puree at the bottom
spoon over a layer of thick natural
yogurt and alternate until the glass is
full of them now yummy there you get
your berries you see the berries on top
it tastes so fresh but now they'll be
marinated and the berries have been
slightly macerated and then finally look
your icing sugar just tap on top they
look just beautiful
now they sit in the fridge to get nice
and chilled okay so if I take three I
promise not to sneeze and you take one
open the fridge door